à Kiev c'est la course contre la montre
tandis que la moitié des habitants n'ont
toujours pas d'électricité le maire de
la ville vient exprimer sa gratitude aux
techniciens qui rétablissent le
chauffage
je tiens à tous vous remercier vous les
3000 employés de la compagnie d'énergie
déplo de Kiev qui travaillait jour et
nuit
grâce à vous nous pouvons annoncer
aujourd'hui que le chauffage est rétabli
dans 97% des foyers
[Musique]
le chauffage est un service vital
car en Ukraine l'hiver s'installe et la
température est passée sous les 0 degrés
mais la Russie continue de bombarder les
infrastructures civiles essentielles et
laissent des millions d'Ukrainiens
privés de gaz et d'électricité de Kiev
au nord à Odessa au sud dérive du Dieppe
à l'est à vivre près de la Pologne
je lance un appel à tous s'il vous plaît
faites des réserves d'eau chargez vos
téléphones pensez aux communications
préparez avec vos proches quoi faire si
les connexions se coupent et voici une
photo du ciel ukrainien prise début
février par la NASA et une autre prise
ce jeudi
selon les Nations Unies le manque
d'énergie en Ukraine pendant l'hiver
pourrait entraîner de nouveaux
déplacements de population dont un exode
hors du pays